subaru has cars that are perfect for
families exploring and for people that
like to put the pedal to the metal i
stop by subaru of las vegas who is
sponsoring this segment to learn more
about the 2022 wrx
[Music]
burton it's good to see you buddy jc
i know we're here today to talk about
the new wrx but i figured before we talk
about the future we need to take a look
at the past i got something cool let's
do it come on buddy
burton i've got a parade of wrx's
[Music]
[Music]
vernon it's so exciting that the 2022 is
coming out but we do have some classics
out here today don't you love the
classics i mean look at this bug eye
isn't that amazing it's it's something
about the wrx i feel like there's a
whole culture that's behind the car you
know it really is and and once you have
a subaru the the first thing you want to
do is make it your own you want to turn
it into something that's unique and and
that's the fun thing and become a part
of a family you know in all these cars
they have like their own personality
let's talk about the new 2022 what are
some of the features that we're seeing
the new one well the brand new 2022 is
is an amazing uh it's the fifth
generation of the wrx and they've
they've really done some things with it
even though the horsepower is about the
same 271 horsepower 258 pound-feet of
torque it's about the same as the last
generation but the torque curve is all
different the drive is all different
it's a new engine 2.4 liter uh
turbocharged dual scroll turbo i mean
it's just a really cool car it was
really cool having these cars this
parade of cars coming to the dealership
and like this one what here there's
obviously a later model one here yes
this sdi is a later model you can see by
just the headlights and the design of it
and the new 22 uh wrx will look similar
it will be an evolution of this design
and okay probably the question right now
everyone's asking how do we get our
hands on the 2022 reservations are open
right now you can go onto subaru.com
soon as you log in there you're going to
see on the landing page you're going to
see a 2022 subaru there's videos you can
access and you can go ahead and reserve
incoming units right from there it's
amazing it's out there people get their
hands on one right at least get the
process going right now and burton this
last one here looks like a classic this
is the granddaddy of the wrxs in the us
1998 2.5 rs a very highly sought after
model was this the first year was
available in the states was 98. it is it
absolutely is wow you've got a big year
with the wrx coming out to 2022 but you
guys are always giving back to las vegas
what are some of the things you have
coming up this year we have some
exciting stuff going on of course every
friday here at this at super las vegas
we do the four-legged friends so we're
doing dog adoptions with the nspca and
then world down syndrome day is coming
up and we've got some a big picnic going
on with the garden foundation centennial
hills park vernon i love the fact that
you're always giving back to las vegas
and i'm loving the wrx collection we
have here today this is awesome isn't it
and i can't wait to see the new 22.
let's take a closer look at this one
here this is awesome
thanks to subaru of las vegas for
sponsoring this segment all the
information is right there on the screen
check out their special offer 1.9
percent financing for well-qualified
buyers for up to 48 months on select
2022 models we will be right back